packed
[Music]
are you we're humbly trying all of us
that's what allah wants to see the
creator see that we're making those
steps even if they're small ones right
start with the jimmy
and from there start praying one time
two three four all the way to five times
a day
allah
so we're going to be stopping everything
we're doing
to do the hood right now i need to uh do
the jumar right now and we'll check in
with you again later here from
time for the danger
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what advice do you have for people like
that young people young people who think
islam is something for you know when i
get 50 67
are they sure they will get 50 60 70. do
you hear that
are you sure they will get told they
won't die
tomorrow next month what what motivated
you
at what age did you start practicing 2
23
why why you died
was there a point in your life that you
were seeking purpose you wanted to know
like why you were created what you're
doing can you explain that to us i
started
asking some questions for myself
[Music]
long story short yeah
it's boston's
so i started asking myself questions
is this all is this why i'm here
is this the purpose of my life so
there were some questions like man there
are muslims around and you are
not like you are not you are not like
them
why you call yourself a muslim so i
started
start thinking discovering i was
watching some movie or tv and
it was a lie like commercials are like
medias i started seeing lies everywhere
propaganda
people think okay i'll just choose why i
gotta be muslim maybe i'll be some other
religion christianity hinduism
buddhism how can people know that islam
is the truth what stuck
out from islam from the rest
our lord is the perfect it wouldn't be
he wouldn't be perfect if he wouldn't
give a perfect religion
so if there is a
any possibility of any or any doubt or
any and logical thing
in this deen it wouldn't be perfect
so only islam is perfect 100
other religions have some things that
are not
there's contradictions discrepancies but
that's a great point and we'll end it on
that
that if you worship a perfect creator
you have to send a perfect way of life
and you have perfection
to the end
in islam you have perfection to the max
in islam you have a perfect
god you have a perfect way of life
and this is all just the game and how
come we are playing this game and we
don't ask ourselves to program it
who created it who designed it
that's my story it's a longer one but
this is a summary
and we just met this brother thank you
made the creator that happens earth
continues
so we just came out of the jummah and
for our guests people are wondering what
i explained to you why we go to gym
we stop work and play we go to thank the
creator we go to hear
a a short sermon about 20
30 minutes tops and then we go ahead and
pray and then pretty much
some people like what are they talking
what are they learning in the mosque go
visit hamas go
i mean come on i mean you gotta like if
you're inquisitive you wanna know
go knock out a muslim uh masjid a mosque
and say can i sit in can i listen and i
can just bring to you know
i'm not gonna sit here and uh go over
you know 30 minutes we'll talk but
in essence what was being talked about
today was
was about good character right being a
better human being
right uh and a higher level of morality
you know being kind and merciful to all
of god's creation
you follow me and there is one hadith
that
stood out that he had mentioned the
person
who was speaking he talks about a man
who during the time of prophet muhammad
he
came into a room and then prophet
muhammad said to his companions this is
a man of gender the next man that comes
through this
through this door and then second day
same thing third day same thing there's
going to be a man who comes in
and the problem is narrating this and he
said this is a man of paradise
so then now look look look one of the
companions of the prophet muhammad very
intelligent he wanted to go collect some
data figure out like man how could if
he's guaranteed paradise
how can i do what he's doing you know
the guy's praying he's fasting getting
up in the night and
praying extra prayers so he asked the
man he says hey can i you know spend
spend a few days with you
and the man said okay uh sure so
he goes and make a long you know story
short
he basically observes what this man is
doing and he doesn't see him doing
any extra deeds than what he does
he actually feels like he does more so
at the end he's like hey
um can you like fill me in the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him he said that
you're a man of gender etcetera etcetera
and uh what is this that you're doing
that's so special
and he was thinking thinking he goes you
know the only thing that he could think
of
besides the obligatory acts that he was
doing was that i go to bed
and i don't have hatred towards anyone
malice envy
that jealousy when someone got something
that you don't have that that creates
this envy in some people he didn't have
any of that he very
he forgives all people who did them
wrong before he goes to bed
and that's what we were learning so how
could people who learn such
teachings be people who are people who
terrorize people
people who are are not the kindest of
people
people who are forgiving who are taught
these teachings
and that's all built on the foundation
of
pure monotheism on pure monopolism
that's what distinguishes islam in all
other ways of life
is that that worship of the creator not
the creation and the teachings
of good manners character and all these
things the few that i had just mentioned
here that's what we were in a nutshell
learning today on the hood
so now we can go back to work go back to
play allow play and enjoy our day
here in bosnia
you know last week's show we had uh ned
iman hafiz nadim
you guys haven't watched it make sure
you tune in and we're going to have the
extended version coming up soon we just
had the preview
of it real short but he was telling me
now the gentleman behind us
right over here he's the person from uh
yes who actually gave you darwah he
helped you know to
islam yes and what were you saying about
him he has a
very interesting life story
he is married to a swedish woman linda
who converted to islam and he has three
children with her three sons
yeah and he his life
his entire life is devoted basically to
islam
and he has when they married
she took kamehameha her dowry
was to that he her husband
teaches her islam and till the rest of
her life for the rest of her life
one one interesting and beautiful method
uh she didn't want money she didn't want
to house
where some people from they want a
hundred thousand dollars
five hundred thousand dollars yes she
was like teach me dean yeah teach me
for the rest of my life for the rest of
my life and he says woman we can take a
great example from that huh yes
get a righteous husband a great
character with good deeds so you can
teach your dean so you can connect you
with your creator
and he says it says every day i give
my wife a small portion of her man
every day i read i write about islam i
learn
something new and i tell that to my wife
and i wonder for example he lives in my
hometown
and he is the guy who when i when i
came back to the mosque he was the first
guy to come up to me
he brought me to his house he i learned
first my first contacted arabic
and books was from mirzad
he he gave me he brought me to the
islamic faculty
in bihac and he he was like a second
father
to me because i was i was i grew up
with tony by mother yeah and
he was the guy who who helped me a lot
in my in my life
and he has a great great really great
story
and one another one the thing what is
which is interesting about this
is that he his father was basically
had a problem with alcohol he was very
he was so far from dean from from
religion
and mirzad gave gave dava to his father
and he the father was very arrogant very
rude
he didn't want anything to hear from
from mirzad
yeah and allah changed the heart of the
father
and the father came back to the dean
also
they are together now and you know a
small town like bosses
which is located in the republic of
cebska
you know there are there is a minority
of muslims around 500 muslims
and 20 and more thousand serbs and
very few people go to mosque but mirzad
and his father basil
every day and every bucket they go to
masjid
and they pray in masjid even if it's
snow
if it's rainy if it's minus 30 or plus
30
they are in the mosque every single day
that's that's the most stranger thing uh
i remember
about mirza and his father his father
now has over 80 years but every day
he reads quran every day he
he reads books he he came back to islam
when he when he was 60 or more years
basically in his pension when he went to
the invention he
he he was brought to dean and every
single day an old man
rides his bike and he goes to the mosque
and he prays
and such a wonderful example
but mirzad is so he's a modest guy
he won't he is very shy yeah but uh
that's the important thing
that's the importance of of sharing if
you care you share
he shared the information with you right
we can't change the hearts we plant the
seeds
yeah the crater's the one who makes them
grow so he planted the seeds he
encouraged you he motivates you
and you ended up memorizing the quran
you're living yourself praying five
times a day
you have a connection with your lord and
your living yes the way you're created
yes yes all because someone actually
cared and they shared yes
basically this is the guy who who cared
but not about
not also not only about me but a lot of
people
he brought the light of islam to many
people
here's an example an example for me and
basically everyone else we have
opportunities we have knowledge
we have something that many people don't
have
and we should we must use that to gain
good deeds
and to gain rewards in this life and the
india
and we have to use what we have
and be the best example of islam when i
saw him
when i saw mirzad and his family and his
wife and his children
you know what i thought to myself i
thought to myself i want to live
the life like this guy lives i want that
kind of life
i want that kind of family i want that
kind of well
i remember i used to go to him to his
house just to watch
how he lives just to watch how he lives
and when he was after sabah you know he
prays
at masjid at mosque he comes back home
and immediately he opens the books and
he makes
tea makes coffee warm coffee and he
reads quran reads books and
until he goes to job he he reads
he memorizes he thinks about islam he
remembers allah
that was so when i saw that that was
this
panel that was so beautiful that i
thought to myself
i want this i want to have a life like
this i want to have a family like this
and this is this is this is the example
how muslins should live when other
people see us
they they have to think to themselves i
want to live
like this guy lives i want to live a
life
like this i want to have family like
this and to
be happy like this basically when you
see a guy who is happy like this
why i want happiness also and that's all
based off
the example of the last final measure
prophet muhammad peace be
upon him who said the best of you are
those who have the best manners
and character and we'll end on this this
ayah from the quran reminds me
of
you are the best nation that
uh you are the best ummah that
came to this earth you
you order but that's what is good and
you prohibit that it's what is bad
and uh you believe it and you believe in
allah
so it comes a responsibility you invite
people to goodness
yes you try your best to advise them
against all that evil
but it's a responsibility as soon as we
stop doing that we
lose what that status that the creator
gave us
thank you again and we look forward it's
coming soon the extended show
with hafiz hadim here assalamu
you